what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the room around up our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week
we got an episode today but first things
first a little bit of housekeeping uh it
is thanksgiving week so i have worked
enough thanksgivings and christmases
over the course of my life as a youtuber
before i was a youtuber that i believe
in giving my guys the week off so we're
gonna be taking a break all this week
after this video for geek culture
explained because i'm literally not
gonna be at home so i'm not going to
have the ability to make a video even if
something huge popped off i'm hoping it
doesn't i'm hoping that there's not
something where they're like hey guys so
like robert downey jr and chris evans
and like chris hemsworth were all
spotted on the set of doctor strange 2.
i'm really hoping that doesn't happen
i feel like it would but i'm giving my
guys a week off so uh just fyi there
will be no videos for the rest of this
week having said that let's get into the
news and let's start with what's
probably one of the more interesting
things here little nos x
wants to play miles morales
reactions to this are exactly what you
would expect it to be
they have ranged from fans of little nos
x who were like you'd be perfect for the
role to people who were not fans of
little not sex being like
no
it's it's been kind of all over the
place but this is a quick little thing i
want to know what you guys think do you
guys think little nos x would be a great
person to play miles morales
in the marvel cinematic universe with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end just kidding don't
leave uh let's move on to our next topic
here
so jeremy renner recently did an
interview with bbc's radio one where he
was talking about the future and even
just the history of hawkeye in the mcu
and how he agreed with a lot of the
sentiment out there which seems to be
that hawkeye had been underutilized over
the course of the marvel cinematic
universe and you know what i got to
agree man i've got to agree jeremy
renner's hawkeye has just been under
utilized over the course of the history
of the marvel cinematic universe by and
large he's been a guy who was just there
now in the grand scheme of things in
terms of all the stuff that was
happening i kind of understand why right
you've got the incredible hulk you've
got thor you've got iron man you even
kind of got captain america
and then you got black widow and hawkeye
i mean i think hawkeye is a little more
useful than black widow black widow can
just punch
and shoot which is kinda cool i guess
but at least hawkeye has like amazing
arrows but beyond that there really
isn't a whole lot for him to contribute
but jeremy renner actually had something
recent to say where he's kind of like i
mean there's a great way for hawkeye to
contribute to the marvel cinematic
universe in a way that we haven't really
seen before
and that's girl scout cookies just
kidding guys although it would be
amazing if hawkeye was selling girl
scout cookies i love girl scout cookies
caramel swirls so here's the thing what
he actually said was he loved the idea
of hawkeye being a guy who launches
avengers west coast or west coast
avengers initially it was the west coast
avengers when it was created by roger
stern in 1984 then it became avengers
west coast in 1989 but it was basically
the west coast version of the avengers
team those of you guys who don't know
what that is back in the day in the mid
1980s the avengers were so popular
marvel was like let's create a second
title and so in the comics vision sat
down with hawkeye and was like hey man
we should expand the avengers roster so
it's not just the avengers on the east
coast dealing largely with east coast
problems but we can actually be on the
west coast as well and so the original
roster as it was created by hawkeye
consisted of mockingbird antigra and
james rhodes who everybody actually
thought was tony stark as iron man
wonder man simon williams which was kind
of cool but by and large it wasn't
really a team of like the unsellables or
like the cast offs but it was a roster
you wouldn't normally expect and because
of that it was hugely popular the west
coast avengers were amazing for a long
long time and that's something that we
haven't really seen in the marvel
cinematic universe the way that has to
be done though is it has to be handled
carefully otherwise it'll feel like
hawkeye and these other individuals are
just being shunted off to no man's land
right like hawkeye you're not
interesting you go to the corn fields
that's what it would feel like right you
guys who recognize the twilight zone
reference that's what it would feel like
right he's just kind of getting shunted
off to the cornfields and that's going
to be the end of hawkeye right like hey
guys i'm going to go leave the west
coast avengers see
the marvel cinematic universe equivalent
of just kind of letting your voice trail
off and that's basically it right that's
that's what hawkeye would be and so i
think it needs to be done in a way where
marvel kind of pushes it and markets it
now if i'm being honest with you guys if
we got a west coast avengers concept in
the mcu
i think it should be a show and if you
asked me this question three or four
years ago should we have a show based on
the west coast avengers in the mcu i
would say no but coming off the heels of
like wanda vision and loki and the
future projects that we're getting like
moon knight and she-hulk there's room
for this kind of stuff right as long as
it doesn't feel hokey as long as it's
not the west coast avengers it feels
like the great lakes avengers right for
those of you guys who know that the
great lakes avengers are goofy and
they're kind of stupid but i think it'd
be a cool concept i think it'd be great
so let me know what you guys think would
you guys want to see a movie or a tv
show that was centered around jeremy
renner and like the west coast avengers
let me know which one you guys would
want to see now continuing on here we're
getting into the spider-man no way home
stuff we got to talk about this man we
got it we got a milk we got a milk
this is for as much as we possibly can
we just gotta milk it gotta milk it man
it's just it's the nature of being a
youtuber let's talk about the missing
member of the sinister six now something
that i do wanna specify here guys is it
at no point in the trailer has there
been any reference to the sinister six
there has not been an instance when
doctor strange has said there are six
villains coming through peter they look
kind of sinister i can't stop them right
we haven't had that happen we've had no
references to the sinister six by dr
octopus no references to the sinister
six by spider-man there's been no actual
thing there now a lot of the things that
people are saying is that well i mean
it's sinister six not really called the
sinister six but there's six of them and
it's just kind of a wink and a nod right
is basically what the what the mcu is
doing and maybe that's true but one of
the things that i do want to specify is
that when this movie comes out it could
just be five guys and that's it right
there's no nothing more there's nothing
more than the five people we've seen in
the trailer right lizard doc ock green
goblin electro and like somebody else
right and that's and that's it right
there's no missing person here there's
no surprise here
but in case there is we gotta theorize
on it so here's the thing one of the
popular theories that's going on out
there is that this is the work of
mysterio now i'll be honest with you
guys i'm on the fence about this the
theory that i've been reading out there
a lot of the theories i've been reading
out there is that this is all an
illusion created by mysterio to screw
with peter parker that's possible but
i'm going to be honest if we get to the
end of spider-man no way home and then
it's basically just a giant psych and
then it turned out to be mysterio i'd be
pissed i think most people would be
pissed most of us would be very very
very angry because it would just feel so
just lazy it would feel so incredibly
lazy to have like all these potential
introductions and things into the mcu
and then throw it all away right that
would just be it would be awful so i
think most people would reject that i
think if anything if mysterio does exist
possibly he's hiding his presence there
and if he is we don't exactly know why
we don't really have enough to go on in
the trailer in terms of the fact that if
mysterio is there what his motivations
would be right i mean say for example he
is hiding himself say for example he is
keeping his presence hidden and he's
just kind of manipulating behind the
scenes or something along those lines
that's possible there's room for that in
the marvel cinematic universe for those
of you guys who never read old man logan
this was a story where the red skull had
basically unified all the villains
really in the united states more than
anything else and then restructured them
so they would stand the best possible
chance of defeating all the superheroes
and it worked the villains won right
they basically killed most all the
superheroes but with mysterio it was
really really interesting because what
ended up happening here is mysterio
actually used his powers to manipulate
the environment on wolverine and tricked
wolverine into believing that the most
significant villains of the x-men had
broken into the xavier institute and
were just attacking and trying to trying
to destroy everything so he killed all
the villains but then when mysterio
removed the illusion it turned out
wolverine had killed all the x-men he
was tricked into doing it by mysterio so
one of the things to know here mysterio
is very very capable what you guys saw
in spider-man far from home i mean that
was cool but in terms of like what
mysterio could actually pull off that's
nothing it is entirely possible that
everything taking place in spider-man no
way home
is the work of mysterio
everything right just potentially
everything here's one of the bigger
issues here assuming we leave out the
idea that it just kind of pisses us off
let's talk about doctor strange i have a
hard time believing that a sorcerer
supreme could be tricked by a guy with
technological advancements it's one
thing when he's tricking shield because
shield relies on technology to achieve
their goals so if you can trick the very
technology that shield is relying on
well then shield will believe whatever
it is that they see and then when you
build on that mysterio's ability to
basically lie to your eyes and trick
your brain into believing that
something's real when it's actually not
just based on what's essentially smoke
and mirrors then it becomes pretty
interesting in that regard and very
capable doctor strange would see through
it like that there's no possible way
that mysterio could dupe doctor strange
it's just not going to work right
between his powers as i have agamotto
all that kind of stuff so that really
kind of removes the entire possibility
of mysterio having any involvement with
this moving on the next idea for the
sixth man is paul giamatti's rhino no
nobody wants to see that moving on the
next person is venom and i love this
it's something that we've talked about
before that while i do love the concept
of venom in the mcu at the end of the
day it would be a little too much to
just kind of cram him in to spiderman no
way home not only that it's been said
time and time again by venom director
andy circus that the desire to have
venom meet spider-man needs to be holy
its own right like that's literally what
sony and marvel studios have been saying
when the time comes that venom and
spider-man meet that's gonna be it right
it's gonna be like these two and if
there is anybody in there they're going
to be ancillary characters at best that
the main focus will be venom meets
spider-man so if venom does appear in
spider-man no way home it'll likely end
up being a post-credits scene having
said that there is evidence to suggest
that tom hardy and venom could encounter
spider-man in spider-man no way home
when you look at the post-credits scene
for venom 2 venom the symbiote itself
recognizes spider-man now when he says
that guy it could very well be something
akin to dr octopus right dr octopus did
not know at least what we've seen in the
trailer he didn't know that spider-man
was tom holland instead of toby maguire
until the mass came off right then he's
like you're not spider-man now we're
just kind of going by what we see it
could be one of those things that
because of how tom holland moves because
he doesn't seem to be as agile or
potentially not as agile or capable of
toby mcguire that he's like okay you're
obviously not my spider-man you're a
spider-man but like let's double check
you know and then he ends up unmasking
and that's when you get the scene in the
trailer you're not spider-man right that
kind of a thing and so because of that i
guess really he says you're not peter
parker but like you guys get what i'm
saying right so because that the venom
symbiote when it sees the scene where
like spider-man's being talked about by
j jonah jameson when they're saying that
he killed mysterio and all that kind of
stuff it could very well be one of those
things where he's like yeah that guy but
he doesn't know it's tom holland now why
does that matter because in the
post-credits scene video that we made
for venom 2 we talked about the idea
that venom the symbiote explicitly
stated they exist across the multiverse
and it's billions of years of history
there and so one of the things that we
said is that if that's the case the only
way to connect the tom hardy venom
symbiote to just the existence of
spider-man in general is topher grace's
venom in the sony verse that topher
grace got the venom symbiote he fought
peter parker write toby maguire
spider-man that whole thing unfolded and
probably was the worst spider-man movie
that was made so far and then in turn
that knowledge because the symbiotes
share a hive mind across the multiverse
that knowledge was spread throughout all
the other symbiotes and that's how you
connect toby maguire spider-man
all the way
to like tom hardy's venom it's the only
way to make it work because there was
nothing in the first venom movie that
pointed to spider-man's existence the
first time we've ever seen any reference
to spider-man in a venom movie it's the
only way you can connect the dots and so
having said that it is possible these
guys could meet but then again if this
is some kind of big sinister six type
event i have a hard time believing
they're going to take what could be such
a huge encounter that would just drive
people to the theaters just for nothing
to see just the two of these guys fight
that they would take venom and just slam
him into spiderman no way home and just
be like he's the missing man he's a
sixth man cool go forward and fight in
the end people wouldn't necessarily be
disappointed but if peter and spider-man
are gonna fight it needs to be its own
thing right so having said that moving
on one of the theories here is that
michael keaton is going to reprise his
role as vulture and have a role among
the sinister six that's possible and
honestly i think it'd be a great little
wrap around a spider-man homecoming to
be quite frank with you guys this is the
spider-man trilogy right this is where
it all seems to wrap up we're being told
that spider-man no way home is basically
the spider-man equivalent of like end
game right people are even calling it
spider-man in-game it's kind of the
colloquial name for the film so having
somebody like vulture appear in this
while he's not by any means the guy
who's going to turn the tide right you
know like oh my god you know andrew
garfield and tom holland and
and toad maguire they've defeated the
green goblin and they've defeated you
know sandman and electro and all these
guys are all defeated but here comes
vulture and he's gonna turn the tide
right nobody nobody would buy that
this is not gonna happen but it would be
a great way to kind of circle around
back to the events of homecoming and
bring him in here one of the other
things to keep in mind here is that
vulture is very very capable in terms of
his technological prowess and the kinds
of things that he can build and so when
you look at somebody like elektro
assuming that jamie foxx's character in
no way home is anywhere near similar to
his character in spider-man or at least
the amazing spider-man with andrew
garfield we don't know if he would have
the technological wherewithal to build a
suit designed to harness his energies
and then channel that electricity in
whatever way is the most conducive for
him but vulture could so that's one of
the things to kind of keep in mind here
is that vulture could very well be
building these suits that a lot of these
guys are using that they're basically
using for their own abilities the goblin
glider that norman osborne has assuming
it didn't come with him which actually
leads us into the next discussion here
which is the character of ned leeds
played by james battle on the on running
theory is he's hobgoblin and i love that
man like for a while i was kind of like
i mean i don't know man like james
babylon is hobgoblin but here's the
thing and this is something that didn't
really occur to me until i was eating
breakfast this morning
you could create a great kind of
connection sort of chemistry there
between tom holland and toby mcguire
because ned leeds is the best friend of
peter parker and the tom holland mcu
spider-man movies who is the best friend
of toby mcguire in those spider-man
movies that he had to fight
harry osborne now technically he became
new goblin if you want to buy into all
that garbage
he was hobgoblin or green goblin if you
want to call him that but he was
basically the hobgoblin s character
that's a great way to kind of bridge the
gap between those guys right toby
maguire's like yeah man i had to fight
my best friend too uh i mean i literally
set his head flying into a rail and then
he woke up and didn't know that we were
enemies and i was like yeah man we've
been friends for a long time here
you know we never fought
it's cool bro you know like eventually
memories come back and then things pop
off again which i'm still gonna say to
this day that opening fight between
harry osborne and toby mcguire still one
of the best opening fights or like just
fights in general of any comic book
movie ever made like even now 2021 it
still holds up it's amazing it's just an
amazing scene but you take that concept
and then you apply it to tom holland
that perhaps norman osborne's green
goblin infects ned leeds right i mean
that's one of the things that we know is
that green goblin loves taking away the
things that are the most important to
people especially spider-man he killed
gwen stacy in the comics he's done all
kinds of things like that just to get to
spider-man and try to destroy him on a
personal level infecting his best friend
with the goblin formula and then turning
ned leads into what's basically the
hobgoblin is a great way to do that and
it bridges the gap because now tom
holland is basically experiencing the
same thing that toby mcguire has because
if there's one thing that's become
apparent over the course of the mcu
movies tom holland's character is
experiencing a combination of the things
that toby maguire and andrew garfield
had gone through right like in the
trailer tom holland says i can't save
everyone andrew garfield said that an
amazing spider-man 2 that if it is a
scene where ned leeds is infected by the
green goblin formula and becomes
hobgoblin that mirrors the experience of
toby maguire fighting harry osborn so
there's a lot of similarities a lot of
things a lot of layers that are kind of
being caked on here from the previous
spider-man films that are all sort of
coalescing and tom holland basically
learning the same lessons that toby and
andrew learned much earlier presumably
in their histories or their careers as
spider-man so let me know what you guys
think about the idea of like ned leeds
being hobgoblin in the mcu
i think it'd be cool now one thing that
i do want to touch on here there's a lot
of theories and rumors flying around out
there about this idea of the opening
scene or at least that scene in
spider-man no way home where doctor
strange is like at like the the burning
flame of like the statue of liberty and
like the portals opening and he was like
they're coming through and i can't stop
them you know and people are like well
who are they you know some people are
saying that the color of the energies
that all the stuff is kind of circling
around looks very similar to the color
of the energies from spider-man into the
spider-verse so it's like other
spider-man coming in honestly i think
that's just the arrival of the the bad
guys right like green goblin and all
those guys showing up here it does kind
of ask the question where else is this
happening because i have a hard time
believing that like the multiverse is
collapsing right is kind of coming in
and then like only those guys are
showing up right if these portals are
happening if the multiverse is basically
breaking open and these portals are
appearing
i would have to believe they're
appearing
all over the world right like it's
happening at different places across the
world not just the world the whole
universe right so like on on on the crew
home world right like these portals are
opening up on the scroll home world
these portals are opening well i guess
the scrolls don't really have a home
world anymore do they got destroyed but
like all these different portals are
opening up across the universe in
different locations and they seem to
also be opening up on earth now it could
be the earth is the focal point but this
could really bring in what a lot of
people are suspecting which is the
introduction of king the conqueror in
some capacity one of the things that i
really like about this theory and again
i don't want to spend too long on this
but one of the things that i really like
about this theory is people are
basically saying that spider-man no way
home is the other side of the equation
of doctor strange too right that the
whole multiverse is going crazy the
universe is going nuts portals are
opening people who are showing up who
are not supposed to be there and so
basically the events of spider-man no
way home take place while doctor strange
is out doing his thing capturing these
various villains or potentially even
heroes that are appearing in the
universe that are not supposed to be
here because again i have a hard time
believing that it's just these handful
of guys from the sony verse that are
coming here and that's it there's no one
else anywhere from any other universe
that's appearing here i think what this
is doing is what i've been saying it's
doing which is basically setting the
stage for merging all the all the
multiverse into a singular universe
right so the fox universe and the sony
universe are all just part of this giant
amalgamation that we call the marvel
cinematic universe and then you just go
forward from there but moving on to our
next topic apparently jared leto came
out and said that like the haircut for
suicide squad needs to come out right
the cut named after the director who
thought it was a good idea to name these
cuts after the right it's it's a
director's cut literally hollywood has
been making these
four decades they've been around for a
long time right like the snyder cut
it's called a director's cut it's not a
new concept
it's basically that like that's that's
that's all it is i mean i guess you can
make an argument that the snyder cut is
the cut of the movie that is totally
unaffected by what's going on with
warner brothers but like we kind of know
warner brothers sanctioned it and they
were also instrumental in the creation
of the snyder cut and so it's not like
zack snyder went out into a field with
an iphone and grabbed the cast of the
justice league and then just started
shooting extra scenes and then added
some green screen effects to it and then
released it to us in a four by three
ratio no one of brothers had a hand in
it right so it's time for us to actually
start calling them director's cuts
because that's basically what they are
having said that no one wants that cut
jared leto no one's asking for it with
scott snyder you could kind of make that
argument because he had to leave the
project part way through or he was fired
from the project part way through
whether or not he was fired or chose to
leave depends on whether or not you're a
fan of zack snyder but you can make an
argument that it wasn't necessarily his
film right the joss whedon came in made
adjustments made changes and so that was
it with air it's kind of the same way to
a degree but a lot of people are saying
well you know warner brothers were
involved and screwed up no no the movie
was garbage jared leto it was bad and no
amount of air cuts are going to fix that
right nothing's going to improve that so
move on man this would be like yeah okay
guys whatever the movie was garbage we
all know it was garbage the one that
james gunn made was infinitely better so
let's just kind of ride on right on that
train and just call it a day like look
guys i totally understand you want to
get the actual cuts of your favorite
directors and that's fine but getting
your favorite directors cut does not
automatically mean the movie is going to
inherently be better than it was before
with zack snyder's cut sure it was
better than the original justice league
but that's because he had time to go
back and look at everything everybody
hated and do it differently right so
it's the second bite of the apple right
it's like it's like a remake of a movie
right it's like somebody coming back and
saying okay i'm gonna remake the movie
that i originally made because everybody
hated these things about it and then i'm
gonna fix the things that they hated and
then add a little more footage and say
see guys it's my personal cut that the
studio didn't mess with no you're just
correcting the mistakes that you made
whatever man like let's call it a day so
i don't know i mean let me know what you
guys think about this right do you guys
want to see the air cut do you guys not
care about the aircut i have no idea but
regardless moving on to things that
actually matter charlie cox this guy's
coming in guns blazing right okay so
this guy is gonna have
this guy's got his hands in all kinds of
projects he's going to be an echo he's
going to be in she-hulk we already know
he's going to be in spider-man no way
home and it seems like all that's
setting the stage to bring him in with
daredevil's season four or daredevil
season one i don't know exactly how
they're gonna do it i kind of hope they
relaunch it to a degree if i'm being
honest i kind of hope it's a daredevil
season one they sort of start over again
and just sort of call it a day or the
very least just kind of re-rework it but
daredevil season four also makes sense
because i guess they're gonna take the
stuff from the daredevil series in
netflix and just make it in continuity
which they can do it was so far removed
from the mcu that it didn't really
involve the mcu but it kind of involved
the mcu so it can kind of go either way
there's room for them to just kind of
throw it in there and just be like yeah
man it's in the mcu cool that's it right
and that's and then you're done right
i'm i imagine that once they get all
that daredevil footage if they haven't
already and it's out on disney plus
assuming it's not already because i'm
not aware of the daredevil show is on
disney plus i imagine you're probably
going to see a lot more scenes in the
show that you didn't see where you're
gonna have like the new york backdrop
and you'll see like star tower or like
avengers tower or something along those
lines things that firmly place it in the
mcu and it's actually there not being
alluded to right so like the events of
avengers are not the event it's hey guys
remember when those aliens came from
that portal in the sky and like attacked
us for a while and the avengers showed
up and iron man almost died yeah man
that was crazy foggy
god i'm surprised we survived that and
like that's that's what you get as
opposed to like you guys remember the
event
the thing we don't reference because i'm
jeff loeb and i'm in a pissing match
with kevin feige and i'm pissy because i
can't be the one to leave the marvel
movies like you're not gonna get that
right so having said that let me know
what you guys think right i mean there's
not a whole lot to talk about in terms
of the charlie cox thing it makes sense
the guy's a lawyer so he would basically
spend a lot of time with lawyers i think
it would be cool i think it'd be awesome
to see they're doing that some
crossovers between him and other
characters like jennifer walters who is
a lawyer herself i'm excited about that
so let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section you guys excited
about this whole thing this is a pretty
good episode i think keep in mind we're
going to be taking off the rest of the
week to give my guys time to go eat with
their families and go black friday
shopping i know i'm going to be doing
that but thank you guys for watching
have a happy thanksgiving and i will
catch you all later
peace